i cannot wait to eat these they turned
out perfect mmm so good hey guys i'm
parker bates from this is us and today
i'm making my gluten-free chicken
jalapeno taquitos my favorite time to
eat these taquitos are any time for
snack lunch dinner appetizers at a party
there's just amazing the reason why i
started making gluten-free dishes was
because of my brother because we had to
change his diet and he had to go
gluten-free and he was like really sad
because he had to give up all his
favorite foods so one of the reasons why
i started making gluten-free just to
make him feel like he didn't have to
like give up everything the first dish i
ever made was i think spaghetti and
meatballs with my grandma i started
cooking when i was about six i had
always wanted to help out in the kitchen
because i mean there were just so many
wonderful smells coming from there i was
like what if i want to make those and so
i kind of asked but then i was like
sitting over there smelling the food and
then she was like do you want to help
i'm like probably yes on this is us it
was really funny because the writers had
kind of incorporated my cooking from my
instagram in one of the scenes i was
making cornish hints for my parents for
their anniversary and i did it wrong and
i was really upset because i thought
that that was gonna ruin their whole
entire marriage i really liked that they
like incorporated all my like my
favorite things to do inside the show it
was really cool oh
i dropped my cream cheese in the chicken
okay this is this is okay take the foil
out and just roll with it because
everything's fine you make mistakes
mistakes happen continue i feel like
cooking would help me like throughout my
life because say acting doesn't go the
way i wanted to then i could like be a
chef or it'll help me like i can cook
for my kids or my mom i already cook for
my mom but she loves my food and i want
to make other people love my food and
i'm actually working on a cookbook right
now and i have to have 50 recipes so
like we're going through this like big
process our kitchen is a mess and liquid
is like making up all the recipes so far
all of them have been really good
oh my gosh these look delicious i can't
wait to share them with my family and
friends
the texture is like perfect and
gooey and the chicken just makes it just
right and it's just so crispy on the
outside and you just get the wonderful
flavor of the jalapenos and the spices
[Music]
hey guys thank you for watching my video
here's a few tips to help you out if
you're having a hard time shredding your
chicken it's taking forever instead of
using two forks you can get your hand
mixer put your chicken in the bowl and
just shred it it's really easy and
really fast to keep the tortillas from
breaking uh you can put them in a wet
towel or napkin whatever works put them
on a plate and then you can put them in
the microwave and then when they come
out they'll just be a lot easier to work
with amazing recommended
delicious
oh yes
[Music]
you